yeah welcome to this video playing cod
Jang from Sweden and Joey gotten Italian
damn juco piano and it's playing with d3
yeah nowadays this is the main line a
three-year this is very early or Bishop
e7 is probably good anyway
yeah I could take but don't really like
to change the pawn structure in that way
this doesn't really matter much the
rukon anything I can always just put it
back if I want to and yeah let's just
play we should be success is simple yeah
he's someplace and moves anyway so let's
try not to fall too far behind on the
clock okay it's not clear that I need to
do that the rook back but why not okay
he's decentralizing this piece so let's
strike in the center
no okay I could hmm yeah but do I take
it's not really it's not really helping
me let's just increase the
centralization group to the eighth I
could have taken just being equal but
just what I want to control g4 so I said
he cannot play Knight g4 and he's
playing almost instantly anyway so I
know is taking a bit of time hmm you
know okay now i can i know i probably
should take wow it's really allowing
that to be them to get the rukon a to
yeah i know i had to donate seven but it
looks it looks a bit strange queen yeah
i'd like to young Queen d3m yeah this is
the best just to infiltrate quickly and
I need to make sure that how to do that
maybe night here night a 5c form
this is a problem its Queen side is
vulnerable to a night on sea foam you
cannot easily play 93 and adjust take it
I mean I take your phone and this
intense not c4 but also he needs to yes
this is a possibility hmm i don't i
don't really want to take he will deal
with them yeah one we can take with the
Queen mmm not sure i think if i take
here it will take g6 this is not great
ok
it will take with the Queen my ideas
after the capture I still have this 93
ideas I can enter 1 D 2 yeah stop I can
go here yeah it's just weak okay he can
we complain I t3 this is some idea on 93
I can take c 30 s SMS hanging wow just
weakens deform considerably so I'm
removing the Queen to have knight c6 to
deform yeah gather time is the only
issue in this game position is excellent
for black i get i get to d4 with the
night
can try a 93 to d5 I can I can expel
that with the c6 so it's not a big
problem yeah I should have gotten more
out of this but then at some point I
need to I need to speed up
yeah nice
yeah this wasn't really my intention but
Tim maybe it helps that he's playing in
symbols all the time my father playing
the best ones
Aston cannot take
now root time morning b7 coming
yeah now okay okay now I'm okay again
but among 13 seconds
just winning the airport check
okay for coming i'll probably check
check check check check
four seconds hmm I'm not sure what he's
doing white dwarf it on time yeah I
didn't expect that who Wow yeah what the
heck did i do them I really am spent far
too much time guarantee widest white is
completely outplayed I just allowed far
too much play him but how to prevent
that maybe maybe I'm overestimating
things he as possible this is Belgium
group this happiness better before b5 is
just them it's just too much and this is
a badman this is just a band of course I
need to play 94 let's check let's go
back and eat / I need to check this the
problem is that this is just just a big
hole and I get to d4 while I would expel
them with c6 this should give black the
advantage but I'd I just just didn't
really appreciate that be five is coming
so quickly I must prevent that rock d 7
assists better but okay even if I mother
played here I need to of course just go
here and then I can play c6 and I'd get
rid of this piece and this should indeed
be a somewhat better for like not like a
decisive edge but it's it's it's a bit
bit of an advantage maybe cam did maybe
I did have something else Cepheus if I
was really a strange move maybe needs to
do that but it looks it looks ugly
I don't know now this is probably the
point where I gave away most of most of
my plane now I have this coming yeah and
in the game he got so much activity here
that it was really difficult to defend I
mean at the beginning I think it should
restore be about equal but around here
blanka's probably just busted the a porn
is very strong and that was down to 30
seconds if he would just spend a bit of
time here I think he would find the
decisive moves I wrote yet it's still
probably okay for him I mean he hasn't
spoiled anything I hear what be seven
wins but he always this instant moves
doesn't help at the end yes wins
attending Lou Kade and you got this next
he wanted to do something similar but
not sure this still seems to hold as
ugly as it looks but it seems to hold
yeah and here I'm just quick in going to
to the two da porn he needs to go for
counter play like this but you just gave
it can't give it up for no compensation
at all and now i'm just a pawn of still
josh with the the strange thing is i had
10 seconds and still so somehow one on
time weird alright thanks for watching